[Music]
thank you very much kings of and stuff
in that u het ijmeer port beckand in
ecru matrix and he start it and
then we became 2 loaders
pack with 3 2 and f years ago and a
mission is to we waste time and
personal  and precise health care using
along parents
machine learning and specifically
broccoli one to achieve is that passions
all get care the best highspeed
politics of success de for them
and so the wasting time and
continuous learning system
where something doctor learn much more
directly from their own  decisions in step
with if there of the sitchin's of their
colleagues in site c hospital with maybe
of our van tions i could beg all over
the world
eventually and we went mercury
learning software using smart items to
create such a system and  we also want to
this well and spending the scars
resources and sufficient iis bosboom
picasso arno
console continues the rising en wie pink
by making smother josh en saba treatment
we can also produc  es and today all folks
would live fair use case is in not
when intensive care show the week
week inch undead join you later in
debate
outside problem and what where time to our
client a doctors and what try to predict
so
the intensive care you hello dat
exactly the place you get
there in hospital where most quickly
european ties
and brave vitals ein sof continuously
monitored with which we here not ordon
support the striped links it's like
the place where you go to gather
recover and eventually when its
stable enough you  can leave the intensive
care and go back to another part of the
hospital for further recovery arrives go
home
eventually and this decision of went to
discharge ipatient
is de de gypsy and agree to five
hours ipatient an intensive care nissen
challenging
decision for doctor heavy door  the idea
knows one more day one more day after
that it
's the poster and in theory
waiting long is of course all lace
weatherby chance p  atients will get there
but intensive care
bed in it self as cars resource so
darn your passions
coming in part ii and swells would it she
could continuous balance between
is so patients have to go and you may
have enough space for nu passions coming
in
and so  sustainable in new york is a which
doctors decide ok wan chai discharge
suspensions and the negative outcome of
the charging template season becomes
be a month parents weert missions
european comebacks comes back to the
intensive care
and this is his if art production
problem plays so well  a means that
is predicting riët mission risk at any
point in time
eefje considering a passion for
discharge what better ie it mission
risk right now to help support
this is usually when to discharge sam and
i are pajamas us based on all rise of
flight of  science and continues be
monitored prime it will you see three
lines there but this concept shrine
dentist of links continues the measured
and this mode is dan  a component in
software is the screenshot of ar software
and read here what your c is an overview of
an intensive care unit the piper and this is
not real passion detail alright
folks
what the [ __ ] all mb's cliché is
product the track beauty for each
passion  if you were to which the church
on my right now what is d'r is dat je see
them back within seven days and this can
then be used by doctors to the site
which passions eh lets aggression
sentiment
be this church and with patients may
need another day an intensive care for
jump op den of course classic team
done right
the deep neural networks audience and
product is chris much better than
doctors kenzo songs no more detail
and then and then hoor dan wel
sleigh uw dan belief in that
special at in de voor sibel future  by
david we just did a specifically
for this site from and there couple of
reasons why thing that are first of all
detail that snaps foil reflect
reality they all the things that i'm not
measured in de did one already popular
measured in de  detail detail important
and this section through as the doctor to
take that into account and keep getting
considération is a special if
you're talking about more
psychosocial aspects passion tprf
francis die steps links snaps al
khattabi capture digitally
entink secondly wf experience first hen dat
you don't even have medical expertise to
similiar diessen modal who hears then is
mother for may be one a few and ready and
how you can 10 years the talking to
intensive care doctors bc aan de weekly
critters
to understand what is exactly be happening
what poor gate and  parameters by doing
things that reunion in the means
churchill you don't even
continuous feedback loop the weeping dating
scientist and the doctor and i think
yes that s  does he overcome the institute
and the turk and really that is xlii expression the
muslim gate and coercion
zo is a result of that expression touch of
red or be one off the
sources of information doctor who use in
its decision making and other sources
can be light  fair use paws goals mee
wie clinical intuition and sex hour
concept of then richard zips very
strong for some doctors and ferry you a lot
we s hybrid ik de fack you see in some
cases
just looking adaptation and then
experience doctors know what's going on
and aunt and  other off course very
important aspects and mentioned before
is what this situation with pensions
means because if a passion grand espace
beyond intensive care at some point
maybe you want to the site not to treat
anymore because you're ninety-six and you
very good  life and maybe you this sit
families per francis sealing has
to be taking into account to make the
final decision and that final decision is
measurable your doctor so this is keep
you warm too  buy from the sister measurement then
that means
the doctor hasten you want some level
understand what this production would
coming from
hdr image up in order to play voice in the
contacts with all the other sources of
information to make the right decisions
and that means you nothing  to stay lof
in mounds de within 10 zoë believe it's
very important to create this and
facilitate is for the moodle site and
where the carbon is inter puppy grafting
brush de it's too photos en first free
one two great just that an average
descriptions argue that they  make sense
to doctors en dus helps facilitate the
adoption we picas is completely new
technology would er al zo bidt can surf
tip en on the Aarde en de point that you
forge things have lte placer in the
white context and understand why
enthusiastic de de de productions
completely and maybe i went to the more
on other factors hannah experience right
to make the right position on wat te
doen tease productions die said i think
artike  ls
form
nanking these models interpol blom and
today i want to share 3
ways in which i am trying to achieve en
villages de politie
festival transparency on demand het alle
jeee en de scope of de modal
second on a global level sam understand
ability of keep mode  works
and become this doing en and the cake to
zinc most interesting and focus mo
standard
and specifically in turk the buttocks tee off in
those video productions
solesta twitter search of transparency
so may seem really bad boy a hurricane
or wonder who is ok you can show  how it
works but why should
really important  learning pipeline
we die of deeta free change' now rings
models and outcomes at h&m aan de district
what the doctor sheen zwitse and the left
is dating it's view of the
world and then the doctor turns  ers view of
the world
what this shows so you can keep the left
influence doctor shows the
software on the right and he also has
my john post and so threshold the dtz we
use light switch fashion boring and
for that you have to hospital our come from
jar  the peshan's explode coloring
tetra
for temple is inclusion in this xlii we
important because it to exclude it's an
groups of nations food shampoo bucas met
venlo numbers on that the doctor mas nou
dat had the spacious on in the mill hull
i as for the passions de man  on track
dixons cannot be used and she can be
just it and of course can take
them out and make sure i dan product
time what think is also important to
share some gravel edge everyone has been
used for the agent
in order to interpret  because here is the
definition of the came out in this case
weert mission it manager at where we're
talking about readmission in 2d acer and
seven days for john price would be
something you have the chenonceau
in order  to really bord meaning behind
is it patient is you 5% risk for simple
wat feature of yoast
this is the point that maybe not a
briefing is kept shirt in the detail and
maybe some features third doctor
dance team relephant retire star in
the mud where the  xlii wet in the mud
and in the doctor nose pads dan 5% risk
and play some features that are not in
the middle with a version for very
whiskey mee and that bush and door is cup in
the doctor mind
let's a thing like that and 5% race  of
secondary actually it's way be epica
history factors the after thing color de
pines model probably push it up so this
incident something to be very clear
about search that you can a powder in
a row perspective and media what can or
every word in my tank  is a waiter less
important but you can refuel or tanks
like she sign now neatly into
account to it or doctor would drown
bathe the undead level but it could be
useful for more better seville doctor
so far simple what who fnv  and louder it
instructions for use and manual and
which give all the choice is that
now they did site is there explained
step by step and very clearly such that
even doctors the utterances i succeed in is
up but then you wanna ride africans
riet is zo
the next up is detection en je ff doctor
dat users de software has to be trained
before i got your training and then who
explainer most important and choices we
meten en al just about bossche bol
implications of we cubi are squadron too
very basic would it 7 first  app of of
making it more in villages the farmer and the
next web
understanding at the global level what the
middlesex who the link is like this oil
talking about the inputs and the choices so
good mouth you the I jump to one of the
challenges who it  is keep which all
this time series information
into why but because the product is
there what is if they understandable and some
levels you can change your record well
we challenging to explain
i say i was goi  ng to others their
zo who went for my explicit feature
engineering approach
would base click any clothing min min max
tanner deviation count also ein sof
statistical ver goals for first share
as tile it mission al cheese of
differed windows of the admission and
then for every features  so this kind or
to put access and try to
learn a graphic
share and men en ben je do has changed
its features
so are you bang on the feature space
huge sled
what that is all things that if you look at
the value
you can understand  what it means right zo
en macs wife you off some fight
clearing up fursday this is
something you can explain and understand
and this stil yes adapter en a nor any
nam daten signed this can also xlii
follow
what's happening setting that's very
important and very valuable  so what you
can and do you especially the features
of the rose and album a great show the
feature engineering yes actually it's an
the columns and I think critically
beautif  ul heatmaps en dan ensemble lobo
level je cog which features en jack play
a most important to tomorrowland en you
can so closet is we doctors en try to
understand that make sense
or not
be in
trial and the kind of a totoro never
reach
for the model that ruts this haircut
north korean and whether it makes sense
medically ben you can find that in the
video features a pic to turn from
mcv min cup de zwalmbeek u de valium
or je red blood cells and
other eggs in graph the relation
between this predator en de hatched and
in the green line is most important is
surf lingerie going up so higher mcv
mains higher het mission risk and then
if you look up in de leecher indeed is
conform that higher mcv is social it
with higher risk sorry sorry do you
fear validate
ted what the model is doing make sense with
the cleo what this is learning and you can
do is especially all the features so these
very tits
a long  process what this is really the
way to an average mode level really
understand is happening and has
that make sense
zo den wina ok an average this mobile
workshop performs and in all so that's a
push very strange things het
doctor fabré variance price buy and then
the next up is in reality into
individual productions and i think the
extreme east longest interesting to
talk wit drill size
popular what works in a thousand
so cover the screenshot leads would this is
this is what the software looks like and and
jef this passion with a  because patient
risk
ok dat looks very good night ever take
great maybelle des patients can be
discharge but of course our doctor iran
responsible for the care of this passion
zo je mee stil want an old [ __ ] get
more than that before you we de site to
to  to go het wit
en uw vader but how can be how can
we explain this individually because percent
pike's we can see an average what words
most important features but that was not
tell mu  ch about what the moral xlii this
for this specifically because percent risk and
the heavy want to shower cap and what
your koi race fans who knows share this
package to leds are fifty-fifty in the
audience oh that sounds so off link is
really great at  kitsch for
interpolation
and those who have he sash is third
djuz' is such a conception of game theory
to actually make an additional layer
something like
seppe it from the models if you lose
the modo scoop out and then you
shift to try to explain individually
products so using this game theory
brooch
you break into an individual production
into the know that the free features
computer to this production and me
you sometimes market with the magic chair oakley
approximate disparition quite well to
world is so that save you kiev
dysfunction
fx' want to x en hoe is zo'n vice
and then this is super action for magic
het c and then to understand ok what is
the effect of this individual feature on
this in which you put act  ion
that leds defy de second roo what did you
wc premier tate everywhere on chance why
they can remove this individual a
feature wat
indifferent orders oh yes you can you can
permateek basically everywhere options in
must you order to remove it pariente you
calculate the difference  between
the production and white the feature and white
out and that and 6 what the individuals
contribution enough that feature was to
date prediction
zodanga has the emergence of a feature
for this in the video production is the
productivity
mine is the products with wood to the I
so  pretty cool and smart marketing he
had occasionally use it all all texts and
works you guys if you want to share
this paper bikkers is where the asters of
scoop and the ex club lead to medical
problem manager rico pepersaus really
recommend you guys this
when  de use it to explain predictions
for hipo
chimia [ __ ] fellow oxygen levels in
your blood during surgery zo baseclear
that's a 15 minutes het
we want your product if t  hat might help
and researcher ibique als dessert
getting you want to prevent i want to
give medications van finds like that zou
and that image and monitored and
continuously showing what's happening
today van parameters and how its
influence in this production is so
production is coming up zo  set
church and cindy henrici coming down 15
minutes it ok there might be your
problem and display amateurs well rising
and begging the population that is
evento have a very high
like you do such a finger outside it
settings quite cool and how this works
is  you have is
and this fish migration lord why i see
this high pad simyo risk
in this case it is to point for sites to
point for time 6 hajus en fridge and
then you can break it down into ok wat
features Droog this risk to be higher
than ever cho tidal volume chance or
brakes between this is how it works of
wood
looks indiana the result
what you do is and how this user testing
with twenty five doctors from tree lights
hospitals i  n the netherlands
time to or testing the
in to put the panel based on
the shared values ​​to explicitly it works
if they understand what this productions
from doing because of course and they
did so we can always be pretty
excited I shovel where it's cool
package had it your job do that
so if we have the and supported
experts happening and want to take you a
grieve so processes lobith kisses was
very interesting
and what works and when in work if him
so gone and she is main screen and
now  what you want' door if you want to
understand this one percenter edge show
you what is driving the swine percent
just about now medical and die channel screen
you can click on an individual patient
and a got more information about the
production they make the first attempt to win  it
looks like this
to the left you see how this
production level head over time so we
have interesting leads is there is king
d'haene rappers is stabilizing that so
it you perceived use  ful and aan de right
whale image is inter turn the panel
based on the ship values ​​zo suzie
5 products rs' and jazz js wings on
blood pressure and you see the wat kan of
great with use of the first x adjust
meme tchité essence is a  neurology
course odom chose a score about the in
tiger at mission en en de woman us now
and then in the background
check this was the most important
product there for the individual patient
so word moonshot' and then with me the
distinction between producteurs
de rai  risk increasing widget is the
search and if you click on the right you
can also see the one side or die trying
to risk
my show that sounds like it could be
useful
and who is this site is always was very
interpol and very useful but as
share  some examples of what we want
to do we want les interbrew bold and who
was your highlight so i will post can
this mtv so i will post please note you
concerning your magazine can asterisks x
plant there what this is ex-lease
catering clothing the number of measurements
the defense with you in the last and the
first day and it was that creasing would
last day with higher than the first day
so has discount
and unfortunately did was five the first aid
orphaned the delta chair and is negative two
and  his effect other may know knew
so
this ex now not that easy to understand
for doctor wide zo is home grime
escher this more often so that ran when
we at the with why this very complicated
feature engineering dat youtube blog die
showing dat yes dat turn up  to work very
well
will you and also some doctor who
actually wandering through
which cd music  to
shopping night that's right this is
definitely what you don't want so from
this first attempt to learn how not to
make
it interpol what this would be a
work five conclusions that do here where
that wa  t is the bar of the typer
bicycle engineer is too complex is
least to be able to explain the plateau
let mayhew samwell jobat explaining why
not used it is quite complicated
do you have your watch out that they soon
such a kso effect so you
by  implementing the feature in floating
disc richest efteling not what were
suggesting en or so
gee escort agency people the
adwords value over the in tiers t
that would us quite simple at the simple
score
maxlead in reais that doctors never
calculate the app which over the in  tiers
they know what's make sense one you come
and an intensive care ben maybe it's
like 3 en Oranje Lieve s'pose 215 wat
making the ever cheese after one or
theory lessons
for an efforts patient' dna sale
clear that saw that only know if an
average  of nine is that does labor and
quiet even though it's a very simple cold
relation it was wet min
even not something and numbered and look
at on a daily base is not all is not
easy to excusez
oh yes da  t mix en sorbets hired at ditch
so van hoe je dit not think
about enough and also some features
you soon serve small gland elephant
meaning and ever look at this ever en
naudts in de model may be done something
but it's difficult for myth understand
why it's in de in de molen she dat dear
good measurement is adding value write this
also did were friction cabinet
with which kingdom both pinxten
afterwards doing get what if you're too many
of those in your in terpen de butt typ
en demise tinka thanks  it is and that
can that can the grid peach and so
this is a fine balance and yes also this
specific panel rabbi the other on-site
there is increasing and of the one side his
degree zing was like lobith
i think feel in my site picas
dead sea jazz that you have everything iko
import en sap en dan for simple but it
is a high-risk you want to know much
more outside
risk increasing factors and the file or
is no muslim antinori wist equi-theme
our that's als  there is dare to that
family
so danny has is now persian add them to
where i spend it is meanwhile politics
and panel and now i think it works much
feathers wel highlighted and coming back
to the previous page is we change so
have big red disclaimer  all causality
do not assume that if you influence the
spectors the risk report is the
collation that can it i
how you need some features that did
not at permar study model and doctor of
change wide receiver in their
something of
analyzed and type of sixth balance  and
remove such a steel frame of some too
complex feature engineering i find was
not really need where i like to show de
tot en features order on the shared
values
independent of up or down risk
everything or decrease in show in this
shampoo lucy de green german  opinion this
for spar biological know you see you much
more with the crossing factors and which
makes sense kiss danny ranchers fitting
handcuffs and standing water is cash
flow and  additional context u de
features and that thing that's quite
interesting to see a bij marcus one you
wanna come back to this x number of the
theme juicy ass core of na een that was
may be difficult to endure pt' has jc
for an education teaching level
dennen doctor nasa so this is still by
the tip lilo en zo dik is that show
context the doctor helps understand
why it is in their en wat is what is
feature is doing and i'll come back to
that in de la urgent
zo'n  next up set again a now working
hard to make you mine turbo show us some
ideas that working on to further improve
this
sister
interplay beauty
panel so truth in public wants ie cool
is the ex tent is almost all by allowing
users to click on an individual
feature and then this and is still box pops
up and keep square so i would model a plan b
feature is oxygen situation
the maximum value over the in tire at
mission and is night i hate percent and at
first glance the doctor becomes inc my 2%
oxigin situation that is very good at
skyhigh the range for help those critters
intention eat ninety and 100 so  [ __ ]
what is the maximum value and decorate
ringlet mission so that means it zweeloo
of the role the mission is generally loo
the dress never in except my 2%
just as very big difference in how to
interpret this such thing expert
saves feature it is mad king de  risk
on the bed and
in view with click on it and see the
distribution of these values ​​for all
nations and then the red line shows where
so we is now then you is
explicit at bloso this maximum value zweeloo
en lo action and saturation ever doctor no
understand
what this feature sexy during and why
in the striving to his down-cast disick
samos men at three doctors
he do not get blown sir save till the
cast is a very good would j  e what's in there
not exactly century at this feature
en gatiss xtc and than the other but you
[ __ ] kind of shampoo shower progression
over time that this additional context
where your associates okay your ex now sed rest
is maxview what the old days before it
was so  lobi leverage and set i and this
she disappears to show so its point
15 your kind bru die close effect is
even marx play more for those doctors
the heat to the stentor de the tales
and they just all of them then you can
click on the features  and really get
like johan other hut and then adding
this would be wine eyes free can achieve
this would come of things is bounced you
the productions for jumper using some
kano beast
modeling work atmosphere menting lobith how
the web truth inc
so i shampoo where the conference
bounce rvh in the ministry is also a
pink white realistic because when some
a chance in student intensive care dfs
i would there
problem not gonna be discharge which
means this time profession sarnath of te
see in modal
zo when you want to have production for
the stipe of patients with quite
uncertain
your bike hailo big swf are see many
european
ties de ratio in daraa discharged right wie
van carly david some point where i say
which does not rush critical read  and
show them but
you because you can af en briefing said bye
bye
en lies conference bounce you can add
some information and then you reach spek
de monastery they come to discharge
number [ __ ] en de marrekrite operations
will probably be more certain you will
be about them  because we've seen many
patients like the zoey know what happens
in the palace large quite coolness shares
his work in progress' wat wat britons
an experiment white second
sorry f discreet in boosting modder
she's having a good [ __ ] in the software
beige neurlet  and who
looked at which could actions this
creature now on the second model is
uncertain and did you
bring it back to the first model and
remove box and pass  ions of your mother
you see that the one risks up and if
you remove it
more than 10 20 percent would your ego not
little patient or de did alef but most
and certain été percent is there air and
how you product this perfectly clean so
with insects mobile  you can say
something about to certainty that seems
to correlate also with a certain power i
product dit met de force model so that
quite interesting and still very much
work in process mining heavy promising
two die further into this and the more
white
must uncertainty was for me  before
moving very and certain ik simples
because i just not ready and at some
point
station the production en black white large
could be nutrition spanish and because the end
with he think we second bv cool
is durable pain of scientific study
where i try to
measure  wat de Liefde added value is af
adding this in turn ability pain of
purchase and a huge and share this one
percent this may be better off but some
fresh a water bottle a turk de  buttocks
tea and together understand how this really
helps doctors there who qualitatively
floor the user test think it really helps
what they all quantify it and test
be the ex lead a study supplication
there such cool papers if we that there hard
working on this
so touroperating interbuild it is very
important for
machine learning in many different ways
working on and yes you can remove the many
different levels on your shirt i
already do in many different ways and hope to
have convince you loved and love it this
morning tanks  what
[Applause]